one day each week jamie and brennan have
a chore to cook dinner for their whole
family but they do get to choose which
day they cook on sunday night jamie
makes the following proposal
let's roll the six-sided die if it's a
one we could cook on monday if it's a
two week cook on tuesday three wednesday
four thursday five friday if it's a six
then we roll again until we get a one
through a five
but who will cook
dad always gets home around five o'clock
if he gets home before five o'clock on
the day we choose you cook dinner so
this is jamie talking so before five let
me write this before
we're just in a color that's easier to
read
so before five
so jamie's proposal is
before
before
five o'clock
then brennan will cook
then
brennan
brennan
and then if he gets and then if he gets
home after five i'll cook dinner so i
guess five or after
five or after
five or after
jamie
jamie will cook
jamie will cook
below is a frequency table that shows
their dad's arrival time so far this
year assume the table represents the
true probabilities of their dad arriving
before and after five on each day
is jamie's proposal a fair way of
deciding who cooks dinner
so let's think about it so first of all
do all of the days
his proposal right over here or her i
don't know if jamie's a boy or a girl if
if the proposal on the table says
essentially that they're going to cook
on monday through friday so it's going
to be a weekday because there's no way
to get a saturday or sunday because if
they roll a six they just re-roll and
then they get something between one and
one and five
so when you think about it it does look
like every day has a one-fifth chance or
you could say a twenty percent chance of
getting chosen
there's you might say well you know hey
isn't there just a one-sixth probability
that that
that
that that one one of the days will get
picked on on the first roll that's true
that's the first roll but then if we get
a six then we keep rolling we roll and
roll a roll again until we eventually
get until we stop rolling sixes and we
eventually roll something that's non-six
and they all have an equally likely
outcome there's no favoritism towards
monday or towards friday so if you have
five equally likely outcomes so if you
have monday
tuesday wednesday
thursday and friday you have five
equally at likely outcomes and those are
all the possible outcomes then they each
have a twenty percent they each have a
20
chance of
happening and we could draw a fancy kind
of probability thing to show this that
okay they have a 1 6 each have a 1 6
probability on the first roll but then
there's a 1 6 probability roll again and
then they have a 1 6 roll after that and
you would have this
essentially this infinite sum that would
come out to be 20
for each day the easiest way to think
about it is one of these five outcomes
is going to happen and they're all
equally likely so it's 20 chance of each
but that by itself does not answer the
question of whether jaime's proposal is
fair because if we look over here
before five when brennan would have to
cook and let me make it was it brennan
was the name yeah brennan so before five
this is brennan's situation
brennan when brennan has to cook and
after five this is when jamie has to
cook and if you look across all of the
weekdays it looks like there's a 50-50
chance of being before five or
after five or i guess five or after it's
probably five o'clock is probably
included in that but let's just say it
is so it looks like 50 50 throughout the
week
but on any given day looks like monday
it's a little bit more likely that or a
good bit more likely that jamie is going
to have to cook on tuesday it's more
likely that brennan's going to have to
cook on wednesday it's a little bit more
likely that jamie's going to cook but
not as it's not as big of a difference
as it was on monday on thursday it's
four times more likely that brennan's
going to cook than jamie's going to cook
and on friday it's a good bit more
likely that jamie cooks more than than
brandon so one way to think about this
is well let's just figure out the
probability the probability that let's
say that brennan has to cook on a given
day so what's that going to be
so let's see there is a 20 chance
there's a 20 chance that our die roll
gets us to monday and actually let me
just write that as a decimal
so it's 0.2
and if we are dealing with monday then
brennan has a 5 15 or 5 i should say 5
20
chance of 5 20 its chance of having to
cook
so
so
0.2 times 5 over 20 which is really the
same thing as 1 4.
5 over 20.
then on there's a 20 chance
of it happening on tuesday on tuesday
brennan has a 15 over 20 chance of
having to cook or three fourths chance
three fourths on wednesday which also
twenty percent chance that they're gonna
have to do the cooking on wednesday
brennan has an eight eight twentieths
chance of having to cook that day
so eight twentieths is the same thing as
two fifths
two fifths and then on thursday once
again 20 percent chance they're going to
cook on thursday 16 20th chance that
brennan is going to have to cook that's
the same thing as four-fifths and then
finally on friday which once again
there's a 20 chance that the diet that
eventually the diet gets to we the the
die rolling system gets to friday and
here brennan has a six twentieths chance
of having to cook which is the same
thing as three over ten
so we can factor out the twenty percent
here so zero point two or the zero point
two it's going to be
one-fourth
plus three-fourths
plus two-fifths
plus four-fifths
plus three-tenths
plus three-tenths which is going to be
equal to
one-fourth plus three-fourths that's
equal to one
two-fourths two-fifths plus four-fifths
this is equal to six-fifths
plus three-tenths so let's see let me
write it all in terms of tenths so you
have ten tenths that's one
plus twelve tenths that's six fifths
plus three
tenths
gets us two that gets us to twenty-five
tenths
25
25 tenths which of course is the same
thing as five halves so all of this
stuff right over here simplifies to five
halves and so we get the probability
that brennan has to cook
brennan has to cook that week
brennan has to cook is going to be equal
to zero let me do that purple color
0.2
0.2 times
5 halves times five over two well what's
that going to be well 0.2 is the same
thing as one-fifth
times five halves which is just the same
thing as one-half
so we've just established that brennan
has a one-half chance of having to cook
that week which means that jamie has a
one-half chance of having to cook that
week and there's a good there's a this
was a pretty good indicator that that
was going to happen right over here that
there's a 50 chance that it's going to
happen before five o'clock and a 50
chance it's going to be five or after
and on any given day there's equal odds
20 or equal probability 20 chance that
the the cooking day so i would say
jamie's proposal is fair yes jamie's
proposal is a fair way of deciding who
cooks dinner and frankly which day of
the week it is
what what is the probability that
wednesday is chosen and brennan cooks
dinner so we've already we've already
thought about that there's a 20 chance
let me do there's a 20 chance that
wednesday is
chosen
and
and
brennan has a 2
or has an 8 20 its probability of b of
cooking that day eight twentieths is the
same thing
eight twentieths is the same thing as
two fifths eight divided by four is two
twenty divided by four is five
so 0.2 times two-fifths that's the same
thing 0.2 is one-fifth
times two-fifths
which is the same thing this is equal to
two over twenty-five and if we wanted to
write it in terms of a percentage if we
wanted or as a decimal this of course
would be the same thing as zero
point
zero point we multiply the numerator and
denominator by well if we wanted a this
is the same thing as 8 over 100 which is
equal to an 8
chance the probability that wednesday is
chosen and brennan cooks dinner is 8
or 0.00